they just keep coming
there's so many of them
if you've been to Vancouver every
evening
there are streams of
all fly across the sky pumpkin face
misses
there used to be a big forest just up
here but it got ripped down because
people wanted to develop on it and so
now the crows don't really have a place
to go and
so basically they find whatever place
they have and a twilight leaf every
single tree and horizontal surface gets
completely covered in current now the
best thing is when they go down this
forest guess what they choose to put in
its place a car dealership
so now what you've got literally
thousands probably tens of thousands of
crows all coming back to the place that
was once their roosting sport right
instead of finding a forest of trees
they're now finding this building a
whole bunch of cars well guess what's
gonna happen to those cars
it also means that my commute back from
work every night is kind of dangerous
because I have to navigate underneath
all of these plays it makes the interest